З моменту загострення конфлікту в Азовському морі
в НАТО неодноразово висловлювали підтримку на адресу України,
підкреслюючи, що застосування Росією військової сили проти українських кораблів
виправдань немає. Однак це ще не означає,
що на заклик Петра Порошенка направити військові кораблі
Північноатлантичного альянсу в Азовське море
країни НАТО відгукнуться позитивно, вважають експерти.
Український президент Порошенко забуває або невірно розуміє дві речі.
Україна не є членом НАТО, а це значить, що союзні зобов'язання,
які діють усередині НАТО, на Україну не поширюються.
Можна по-різному до цього ставитися, але це факт.
По-друге, Росія і Україна підписали угоду в 2003 році
про спільне користування Азовським морем. Це означає,
що обидві сторони можуть використовувати Азовське море
для переміщення цивільних і військових суден. Однак тут є одне обмеження.
А саме, військові кораблі третіх країн туди заходити не можуть.
І це теж радше свідчить про те, що НАТО
не буде відправляти туди свої кораблі.
Однак цю думку поділяють не всі експерти.
Вони визнають, що рішення про відрядження в Азовське море кораблів НАТО
буде непросто ухвалити. Але якщо НАТО і ЄС налаштовані серйозно
і мають намір продемонструвати,
що територіальну цілісність України необхідно поважати,
то час діяти, а не обмежуватися лише словами.
Варто було б згадати, що Франція раніше запропонувала
ідею проведення Євросоюзом разом із США
операції із забезпечення судноплавства в Південно-китайському морі.
Якщо це можливо там, то чому б не зробити це в Азовському морі,
яке знаходиться набагато ближче до Європи.
Росія в разі появи кораблів НАТО в Азовському морі погрожує,
судячи зі слів речника Путіна Дмитра Пєскова, ескалацією конфлікту.
Раніше російські ЗМІ повідомляли про те, що українська сторона
нібито просить розмістити на своїй території військову базу США.
Але спецпредставник США щодо України цю інформацію DW не підтвердив.
Мені не відомо про переговори на тему розміщення
постійної військової бази Сполучених Штатів в Україні.
У той же час у нас існує нормальне здорове оборонне співробітництво з Україною,
таке ж, як і з будь-якою іншою країною.
На питання ДВ про плани скерувати військові кораблі в Азовське море
в представництві НАТО не відповіли.
При цьому відзначили, що з моменту анексії Росією Криму
Альянс істотно збільшив свою присутність у Чорному морі.
Тим часом, голова німецького МЗС Гайко Маас
у відповідь на заклик українського президента повідомив,
що Німеччина не має наміру відправляти в Азовське море військові кораблі.
Що нам зараз точно не потрібно -
то це нового витка військової ескалації.
Ми повністю підтримуємо Україну в тому,
що агресія виходила від Росії.
Але це може призвести до подальшої агресії
і нарощування озброєння з боку Росії.
Країни НАТО і ЄС пОки що роблять ставку на мирні переговори
і майбутній саміт Великої двадцятки,
на якому заплановано низку зустрічей із російським президентом.
З боку Росії, на думку експертів, сигналом про готовність
до співпраці для початку могло б стати
звільнення українських кораблів і моряків.